the two judges here have just decided
they've ruled that u.s government will
be allowed those two additional grounds
of appeal the u.s government was always
going to appeal this decision back in
january it was decided that julian
assange should not be extradited to the
us based on mental health grounds and in
particular the risk of suicide should he
be sent to a prison in the u.s
the team the legal team for the u.s
government had argued
that they wanted to appeal this decision
they're allowed to appeal on three
grounds but two of the grounds were
rejected initially that's what today has
been all about those two additional
rounds of appeal have now been allowed
and we understand the appeal itself will
take place in late october so not for
some time if you remember that julian
assange the founder of the wikileaks
website is accused in the us of aiding
and abetting the hacking of classified
defense intelligence documents uh
relating to the wars in both iraq and
afghanistan which he then published on
his website the u.s said he acted
illegally that he put lives at risk he
said he was trying to expose abuse
carried out by the u.s military it will
no doubt come as a blow this decision to
the many protesters who've been here all
day outside the high court julian
assange himself has not appeared in
person he's appeared via a video link
from belmarsh prison where he's been
held since 2019
it'll take some time i think for them to
digest today's findings but it will be a
blow to them without doubt but that
breaking news just in that the two
additional grounds of appeal the us
government wanted to include in its
appeal have now been allowed